here he comes
hey what's that man was on my mind OHS I
thought I thought I had today off from
my both jobs I got I got my one job
going at 2:30 and then I was thinking
about signing up for a you know open mic
tonight
which would be like 5:30 and that would
be like the first open mic ever but I
was listening to videos on like YouTube
for like other people and most of them
say like don't go like check out an
actual open mic before you ever like go
sign up but you know like almost like
you know what you're getting before
before you kind of don't go up and
embarrass it yourself what are your
thoughts I think this is a really a
question of self-awareness like you can
go there and and suck your face off like
just totally embarrass yourself and be
cool with that like go in and expect to
suck and be cool with that and and it
doesn't it's not going to deter you from
going back again then go tonight and do
it but if you feel like if you if you go
up and totally embarrass yourself and
and then like that may mean you never go
to a comedy club again I never try it
again never try stand up again then get
a little more data more research here's
like the struggle though because I mean
I was like expecting not to have to work
for like anything like you know just
like my mindset to today was like
focusing on that like beat because you
got to be there I guess at like 5:30 -
do you like a sign up and like based on
my schedule it's not gonna work I got
like I got a work my one job at 2:30
which would be catering which is
probably I'm assuming it's gonna take
till five maybe six seven I guess in
like my mindset is like just to show up
and like just to check it out though
like today that it's such a winning
mindset if you can do that like if you
can go there if this is a dream of yours
or even just to try it out if it's been
on your mind for
while the best thing you can do is just
go out and try it and stop thinking
about it and stop over planning things
and just go out and do it mmm that's
like I don't know how long like how long
you be thinking about doing an open mic
like actually actually actually probably
like like the last like week but like
okay how long I've actually listened
comedy though I mean years you know okay
but even that like the faster you can go
from idea to doing something about it is
gonna determine how much you win because
there's a lot of there's a lot of people
who wish they could do an open mic and
then they it takes some years before
they go off and do it so if you're only
a week out
that's actually pretty spectacular like
if you thought about it a week ago and
now you're actually gonna go off and do
it that's pretty amazing the fast you
can go from idea to trying it not and
expecting to be brutal like brutal
especially with with no preparation
because you're gonna be working two jobs
and all that kind of stuff like no
you're gonna go up and just suck right
right it's like the mindset in my mind
is just to you know I mean being 24 just
start fleeing the wall figure out what's
gonna stick what's not and then like
start taking more preparation in life
whether it's with this or like other
things because it's experience
experience experience and I think you
could relate to that like the more
experiences you kind of force yourself
into the more like you can kind of say
like you've done this or like you're
ready for the next thing or the next
thing it's just going and seeing if you
enjoy it even part of the process and if
you want to get better at it you can't
like listen you if you if you wanted to
dedicate the next 8 years of your life
to being a stand-up comedian you could
get really good at it right you could
but trying it like building some kind of
momentum and and do this part of your
story like if you go up right having not
practiced
haven't wanted to do this for a week and
go up and do it and bomb and be like
they'll be laughed out of the place like
in a bad way like get off stage and
tomatoes thrown at you
and then they'll become the greatest
community of all time like that's that's
such a great story man that's gonna be
inspiring tons of other people where is
it you know what I ham Don aha then I
waited six and a half months before I
went off and did my first one kind of
strong right as long as you can handle
the emotional aspect of you likely
sucking and then not taking that
personally that mean that you suck it
means actually that you're awesome like
the fact you would have the confidence
to go out and do the thing that you're
terrified to do with very little
preparation expecting the suck and then
sucking I think that is so character
building I think that's the ultimate way
to build your strength as opposed to
saying I'm not ready I'm not good enough
I'm gonna practice for six months before
I even take my first shot I think it's
the best thing you can do so let's go
thank you all right let me know how it
goes man good luck tonight I will thank
you also if you want to know what I
think and what other successful
entrepreneurs think about building
confidence check out my new 2:54
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days for free I will send
you a 30 second a five minute video in
the morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below if you want to be
more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me if you liked this
video check out the one I made on how to
take action now the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
initiate the action take actually taking
action taking action do the action act
now